Доця…Чотири з половиною роки, Анастасія.
Татова доця… Він так хотів доцю!
Наталія щодня переглядає ці останні спільні фото з чоловіком, де він обіймає її і дітей.
Уже майже вісім місяців жінка не знає, де Сергій і що з ним сталося у жовтні 2022-го.
"У нас все добре!.." Він завжди так відповідав, що у них все добре.
А потім 8-го числа в 11:57 востаннє у повідомленні прислав смайлик.
Я до трьох ночі не могла заснути, я плакала. Важке було передчуття.
А вже 12-го в четвертій годині вечора мені з військкомату принесли сповіщення, що він є офіційно безвісти зниклим.
Кажу: "Скажіть, будь ласка, що мій чоловік живий". А він каже: "На жаль, я вам цього не можу сказати".
Після шоку Наталія опанувала себе і почала самотужки дізнаватися деталі зникнення чоловіка.
Спершу написала заяву в поліцію та подзвонила до військової частини чоловіка.
А також розшукала родичів інших побратимів, які зникли з її Сергієм поблизу Бахмута.
Ми знайшли одне одного і контактуємо з цими родичами, ми одне одного підтримуємо.
Одній із мам зниклого безвісти сина, який був з моїм чоловіком, продзвонив побратим і сказав, що вони в полоні.
Підтвердженого, на жаль, немає нічого. Куди я зверталася?
В СБУ, НІБ, Червоний хрест, ООН, ГУР. З деяких інстанцій загальні такі відповіді, ну, вибачте, ні про що.
Наталія цього місяця вкотре заходить у ці двері - на прийом до Уповноваженого з питань зниклих безвісти за особливих обставин.
Тут таких, як вона, відповідно до ухваленого торік закону, особисто інформують про етапи розшуку.
Доброго дня!
Пошуки ми не закінчуємо! Навпаки, ми ще більше працюємо над цим питанням!
З останньої нашої зустрічі нічого не змінилося…
Звіти про пошуки для рідних у Офісі уповноваженого дають раз на кілька тижнів.
Спілкуються індивідуально - так, як із Наталією - або онлайн з групами людей, чиї родичі зникли в один час і в одній локації.
Працюємо з представниками правоохоронних органів і військових.
Надають нам відомості про певні поховання.
Три людини. Одну з них ідентифіковано.
Перше, про що просять родичів спеціалісти з пошуку, дотримуватися інформаційної тиші.
Тобто не намагатися давати оголошення про зниклих у соцмережах.
Нерідко інформацію з відкритих джерел самі ж російські окупанти можуть використати проти зниклих осіб, які перебувають у полоні.
А ще нею можуть скористатися шахраї, які виманюють кошти у родичів
за неіснуючі деталі про місцезнаходження зниклого.
Найбільші складнощі з пошукоим, каже Олег Котенко, виникають через невідомі обставини зникнення людини.
Нерідко це відбувається на нині окупованій території.
Уся наявна достовірна інформація про зниклих, каже уповноважений, наразі є у новоствореному Реєстрі,
звідки рідні можуть отримати витяг. Нині реєстр налічує понад 23 тисячі особових карток.
90 відсотків із цього списку - військові ЗСУ.
Якщо ми навіть знаходимо людину, ми ставимо позначку "знайшовся" чи "співпадіння по ДНК", "звільнений з полону".
І наразі в Офісі уповноваженого ми розшукуємо людей, про яких ми зовсім нічого не знаємо - це трошки більше семи тисяч.
Щодо решти також є інформація, вона додається.
Наприклад, ми знаємо, що він в полоні, на рашистських телеграм-каналах ми бачимо, що людина в полоні.
Але його можуть переміщати з однієї колонії в іншу колонію.
Ми також це фіксуємо. Є ж дуже багато проукраїнських наших, які перебувають на тій території, вони допомагають нам у пошуку - фото, відео поховань.
Та іноді фактів, зібраних онлайн, недостатньо, аби підтвердити статус полону чи загибелі бійця.
Тоді у пошуках застосовують міжнародні зв'язки.
Приміром, долучають Координаційний штаб з питань поводження з військовополоненими.
Тут серед іншого займаються також питаннями зниклих безвісти та координують пошук за участі
Червоного Хреста та Національного інформаційного бюро, яке напряму співпрацює з правозахисниками у Женеві.
Туди інформацію про українських військовополонених іноді надають росіяни,
тож серед імен полонених є шанс знайти зниклого військового ЗСУ.
У координаційний штаб звертаються особи, які взагалі не знають, куди рухатися,
що робити, який орган за що відповідає. Якщо у нас є можливість вирішити питання на місці, ми це виконуємо.
Це унікальна структура, якої раніше не було в практиці.
Вікторія Цимбалюк як волонтерка починала роботу у координаційному штабі на етапі його формування торік.
Сюди вона прийшла з власною історією втрати - свого рідного брата їй довелося шукати
самотужки у полях щойно звільненої Харківщини, через півроку після того, як він загинув.
Каже, тоді місяцями не знала, куди йти по допомогу з пошуками.
Нині ситуація, порівнює вона, кардинально інша.
Зокрема завдяки активності родичів зниклих і звітуванню держави перед ними.
Звертаюся тільки до влади з проханням: допоможіть хоча б знайти, де моя дитина знаходиться!
Вже більше року я не маю жодної інформації! Мене "футболять" з одного місця в інше!
Результати зустрічей з рідними у Координаційному штабі - різні.
Цій жінці, приміром, повідомили радісну для неї звістку: після року пошуків з'ясувалося, що її син живий і перебуває у російському полоні.
Я відчувала, що він живий! Надія - це те, що мене підтримувало, я вірила, що мій син живий!
Зателефонували з НІБ, Національне інформаційне бюро, що мого сина підтвердили. Де місцезнаходження - невідомо.
Але Росія дала підтвердження через міжнародний Червоний хрест.
Пані Сніжані, як і іншим родичам зниклих, у Координаційному штабі допомогли з оформленням необхідних документів -
на щомісячні виплати по 100 тисяч гривень як матері військового, що зник за особливих обставин.
Та нерідко у питанні таких виплат, каже юристка Ірина Підреза, виникає чимало юридичних колізій.
Як-от із тим, хто саме з рідних має отримувати кошти, і чи у разі повернення додому
військовослужбовець може використати надані державою гроші.
Конкретно прописано, що першочергово право на виплати має дружина.
Наприклад, є дитина від колишньої дружини. І є батьки.
І в колишньої дружини є своя родина, свої діти від цього чоловіка.
Часто батьки звертаються і кажуть: "Як так: дружині все, а нам нічого.
Ми віримо, що син повернеться, і коли він повернеться, не буде коштів, тому що все отримує дружина".
Ще один юридичний парадокс, каже уповноважений Олег Котенко, -
це неможливість оформити виплати для родичів, доки не буде доведено, що особа - чи то цивільна, чи то військова -
дійсно зникла безвісти, а не самовільно виїхала чи дезертирувала.
Людина загинула, дійсно, десь похована на окупованій території.
Вони можуть бути депортовані, вони можуть бути на території Росії, і там залишитися.
І ми ніколи не дізнаємося, що відбувається.
Вони також є в Реєстрі, але поки ми не розуміємо, поки в нас не буде свідчень, що у нас людина зникла.
Чи він самовільно залишив частину, чи він безвісти зник.
Дані про ймовірну загибель бійця, який у розшуку, іноді отримують зі зйомок дронами або інформацію надають російські військові.
За домовленістю з росіянами, команда Олега Котенка раз на кілька тижнів їздить упізнавати тіла та забирати їх із "сірої зони".
Для цього наразі створено сім пошукових груп за участі демінерів.
За рік таким чином вдалося повернути рідним понад півтори тисячі тіл військових.
Іноді у таких пошуках беруть участь і родичі загиблих, ризикуючи власним життям.
Вони ж не військові. Ми кажемо "слід-слід", а для них це нічого. Зійшов - "Бац!" Людини нема.
Поки на самому вищому рівні не дозволять це робити, ніхто туди не поїде.
Щоб прискорити впізнання, ми дійсно запрошуємо рідних, через слідчого.
Процес пошуку безвісти зниклих, каже Котенко, полегшило б нове звільнення українських територій.
Наразі активно відбуваються пошуки зниклих безвісти в районі відвойованих ділянок біля Бахмута.
Нам потрібно відпрацювати ті локації. Якщо ми знайдемо тіла, то вони загиблі.
Якщо ми не знайдемо тіла, то, можливо, вони перебувають у полоні.
І це для нас уже 50 на 50 буде ставати.
Якусь там звістку отримати дуже складно, коли вони самі - російська сторона - не показують наших полонених.
Попри непідтверджені дані про місцезнаходження чоловіка, Наталія вірить у його повернення додому живим.
Сон був мені, що він прийшов, я його обіймаю, цілую і кажу: "Скажи мені, будь ласка, де ти, ти живий? "
А він так тихо мені відповідає: "Я живий".
"Я тебе прошу, снися мені частіше". А він каже: "Добре, буду снитися…"